what's with the jeans and I don't get my
farts at college anymore yeah I was
thinking that spice girls home now how
do we change the words that don't maybe
well are you gonna fuck all my friends
yeah then you also said that that's a
pretty accurate
you said they thought that that's kind
of what the song was about and like all
my friends I think that's really better
song so we need to talk about that oh my
god coffee enema woman has a video where
she teaches you to make cheese and human
breast milk that's next one let's play
that god damn it Adolphe Hitler painting
destroyed by a big black hawk well that
might be considered oh yeah
dick okay some I call the violins that
much harm I think so that's so bizarre
it's a big black dick which is weird
yeah here's Maura's Taylor playing just
like kind of Hitler corner he's playing
Marco Polo with these naked
right here you know what that reminds me
of the fuck me in my ass guy that was
that is one of my favorite clips of all
time long time maybe we should bring it
back to the miasma Oh glorious Stefan we
wanted to bring that up yeah that she
was on our show it's for clap no we
should bring up write this down that it
was basically not given the attention it
deserved
yeah I just saw them you know it's
coming and also hey I'm so afraid of our
nanny stumbling across our show she
would get going maybe the show he has a
name I'm gonna play this song first
actually so don't worry ready okay you
ready